je pense que il y a deux types de dérive
euh il y a la dérive par méconnaissance
parce que aujourd'hui on est vraiment
lié que au code de la consommation mais
c'est à la fois très grand parce que le
code de la consommation est très grand
et il faut être honnête pas tout le
monde ne le connaît par cœur et pas tout
le monde n'a cette analyse je pense
qu'il y a un problème de formation
pour nous tous
donc on essaie de faire du mieux qu'on
peut pour s'entourer et être encadré
maintenant
les influenceurs voilà pour moi doivent
faire des formations pour être
aux personnes parce que tout le monde
peut être influenceur aujourd'hui vous
pouvez avoir 18 ans comme 20 ans avoir
un bac + 5 ou pas avoir de bac du tout
et vous pouvez être influenceur donc
forcément vous n'avez pas la
connaissance de toutes les règles et
toutes les lois
donc il faut il faut les former et
surtout qu'Internet est un milieu vaste
ou vous avez tellement de dérives
tellement de dérives c'est à dire qu'on
a rencontré par exemple alors par
exemple il de dropshipping et
dropshipping c'est quelque chose de
légal mais où il y a des dérives
malheureusement il y en a beaucoup plus
que de bonnes que de bonnes enfin de
personnes qui sont qui font du
dropshipping correctement donc là ça a
créé beaucoup de problèmes mais quand on
s'en aperçoit bah des fois c'est souvent
trop tard donc est-ce qu'il faut
interdire le dropshipping ou pas ça
c'est pas de mon ressort mais
effectivement il y a eu des problèmes
donc dans les agences après on a décidé
d'arrêter le dropshipping comme ça au
moins on préserve après il y a eu des
gens qui se sont mis tous dans les paris
sportifs après il y a eu le trading
après il y a eu la NFT après il y a eu
les CPF là en ce moment il y a des
choses sur les pare-brise par exemple en
fait il y a j'ai l'impression que sur
internet il y aura toujours des gens qui
sont malveillants qui vont trouver une
faille pour
mettre en application leur dérive à
travers des sites internet et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit accompagné
là-dessus pour
être prêt à ce genre de choses et avoir
des alertes immédiates